Speaker 1: . OK, let's hear from a few more
people via The David Pakman Show discord,
please sign up, I mean, it's completely free.
I'm selling you nothing at David Pakman dotcom
discord.
Let's talk to oh I don't know.
How about how about Meggan from California,
Meggan or Meggan the Californian.
Is that better?
Said Megan.
Speaker 6: Hi.
How do you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 6: Hi.
This is crazy.
This is my first time calling in.
I listen to you every day, so thank you.
Hi.
So I yeah, I'm from California, as you said,
but I live in England.
Oh wow.
And yeah.
Yeah, quite the distance.
I don't know if you heard about it, but did
you hear about the anti protest bill that
was passed here or at least I did.
Speaker 1: I did.
But I introduced rather I don't remember.
Yeah.
Not passed.
Introduced.
I don't remember exactly what's in it, but
I remember it raising a number of red flags.
Speaker 6: Yes, definitely a red flag raiser.
I just was wondering, like with the introduction
of the anti protest bill in Florida and that,
you know, eventual signing and now this one
in the UK, which is obviously, you know, basically
a cousin of the US, so to speak, like is there
a growing like, I guess, anti protest movement
that is actually.
Moving in a way that we should be genuinely
concerned about, because I feel like it is.
I think so.
I think I could do on that.
Speaker 1: Well, I think the problem with
a lot of these bills is that and to some degree,
there's there may be no avoiding this.
A lot of these bills are designed.
The Florida what I'm most familiar with, they're
designed in a way where it's basically just
the discretion of whoever the hell either
wants to support or repress a particular protest
movement, because they I think with the Florida
one, there was something about once there
is once there's more than three, it's like
some really low numbers.
Like once there's more than three people,
if they are doing harm to property or putting
property at risk of harm, then it can be completely
shut down and people get arrested.
And of course, the risk of harm to property
is so subjective that it's just opening the
door to saying, well, we don't like the reason
that this protest is happening.
So then we're going to apply the law to it,
but then we won't apply it to this other thing.
So I think it's extraordinarily dangerous.
Speaker 6: Is obviously like I mean, not obviously,
but it seems like the only answer to this
is more protest, right.
Speaker 1: But we have to protest before they
passed laws.
Yeah, no, it's I mean, listen, I think I think
there's something else, though.
I do think that this is one of those issues
where you a lot of these decisions are being
made at the state level.
They're really all be made at the state level
or even lower.
Sometimes it's individual municipalities.
It's way easier for people to come together
and lobby their local or state officials than
it is like U.S. senators and U.S. congressmen.
So I think that this is a much bigger opportunity
for people to really get involved and work
directly with your lawmakers to change or
prevent these types of bills in a way that
is not as as feasible at the national level.
Speaker 6: Right, so it's more of a matter
of contacting your local lawmaker.
Yes, that
Speaker 1: combined with going out probably.
Speaker 6: Yeah, right.
OK, so don't don't stop protesting.
Keep protesting.
Yes.
And call your local lawmaker.
Speaker 1: Exactly.
Exactly.
And vote people out.
Vote people out if they support this stuff.
Speaker 6: Yes, obviously, of course.
Yeah, well, perfect phone call.
Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: Where in the U.K. are you did you
say London?
Speaker 6: No, I'm in Manchester.
Speaker 1: Manchester?
Oh, OK.
I've never been there.
I've been to I've been to London.
I've been to Oxford.
I've been to a few other places, but never.
Manchester is a sizable city, right?
Speaker 6: Yes.
I would say it's like diet.
London.
Yeah.
You know, if you want to have a little bit
of a smaller city and you know, the locals
are great, come come on to Manchester.
The architecture is beautiful
Speaker 1: and there are things opening now
with the numbers looking so good in the UK.
Speaker 6: Well, yes and no, it's a it's a
mix sort of thing, like the essential businesses
and non-essential businesses, I think are
open now.
So but you can't go inside of restaurants,
I believe I haven't really been out too much.
You can go and sit in like a beer garden,
which obviously Brits are thrilled about.
Beautiful.
And yeah, it's it's good.
But at the same time, I'm honestly kind of
concerned about the.
Well, I'm always concerned about this government
here, right, with Johnson in charge, so I,
I am nervous about the release of the AstraZeneca
vaccine and stuff throughout the country just
because I don't I don't really trust them.
But maybe that's just more personal.
Speaker 1: Are you wearing a mask outdoors?
Speaker 6: Oh, of course.
I wear a mask all the time, indoors, outdoors,
everywhere,
Speaker 1: even by yourself.
At home, everywhere.
Just all the time.
Speaker 6: You know, personally, when I'm
alone, sometimes I like to be a little risky.
Take
it off.
Yeah.
You know.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, stay safe, OK?
Thank you.
All right.
Very.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate that.
Thank you.
A lot happening there, that's for sure.